Speaker 1: Welcome, everybody,
hope everybody's weekends are
looking good last weekend before Thanksgiving,
as a reminder, we're going to be here Monday,
Tuesday, Wednesday, next week and we will be off
Thursday and Friday for the Thanksgiving holiday.
Few stories I want to go over with you
today. You might remember that the day
after, maybe it was two days after the
elections. In early November, we learned
that the 17 year old son of the Republican,
Virginia governor elect Glenn Youngkin,
tried to vote two times two times. He tried
to vote despite being over only 17 years old.
Well, finally, Glenn Youngkin has been asked about
this, and Glenn Jenkins reaction is to be upset
that the media is focused on what his son did,
saying it's really no big deal. And it's sort
of unclear if Sanford 17 year olds can vote. No,
no, it's not. So this is Glenn Jenkins reaction.
He doesn't like the fact that people care about
the fact that his son tried to vote illegally.
Reports of your son trying to vote for this one?
Speaker 2: Yeah,
it was just it was silliness. I think there was.
There's real confusion on where a 17 year old can
can vote or not. And so he he had had a
friend who who suggested that he might be
able to vote. He went up and asked, I know
my son really was incredibly respectful,
young man. Yeah. And and he presented his ID.
And when they said he couldn't vote, he said,
OK. And he went school. So I do. I am a
little bit frustrated that it's become,
you know, the media paid so much attention
to it. It's my 17 year old son and I really
would like everybody leave my family alone.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So let's see if we can break that
down. First of all, he tried it twice. He tried it
twice. Not once. So it's not just, well, you know,
he just said, Hey, would would you let me vote?
And Oh, well, let me try another place and see if
they'll let me vote. There is no confusion about
whether 17 year olds can vote. You, you have to be
18 in order to vote. Now there's one caveat it's
not even a caveat many people know about, which is
if you will be 18 at the time of a general
election. In many, I think it's in many states.
Maybe it's a federal rule. You can vote at 17
in the primary. So imagine I'm 17 year old David
Pakman at the time of the primary, but at the time
of the general, I will be 18. I'd be allowed to
vote in a primary, even if he was confused. They
clarified for it. They clarified it for him the
first time he tried to vote. So then the second
time was what? What are we supposed to believe
about the second time? And of course, guys, if
Glenn Youngkin Son could legally vote, obviously
he would know that, and his dad would be saying,
All of us are voting for me, obviously. Maybe
they would have even done it together for
the photo op opportunity, like the idea
that it wasn't discussed in the family or it
wouldn't have been if he was old enough to
vote. I'm counting on your votes, son. Are there
17 year olds in this country that don't know that
I knew from age seven that you have to be 18 to
vote in the United States if you surveyed 17 year
olds in high schools nationwide? What percentage
do you think knows that you have to be 18
to vote? It's very high number. We have
an ignorant country in many ways, but
just about every high schooler knows you got
to be 18 to vote. And just imagine for a second
what right wing media would be doing if it was
Terry McAuliffe, 17 year old son or daughter who
had tried twice to vote in an election that their
dad was running. And it's absolutely outrageous.